now this is a this is a Greek general
solution question I think this is part
two actually you had to show this was
the case of n solver okay and again it
looks awful for bunch of silly reason
it's got that powerful so let's go ahead
and do it right first step first step
I can't say you can't list it both of
those steps I'm going to introduce a
substitution just to get my pals down
you don't have to but it does make it
easier okay and then that's factorized
okay so he's a good substitution to make
that you even post with theá--
so you've got four u squared plus 3u
minus one can anyone tell me what the
factorization is
good okay so there you go so now I've
got my two solutions for cos squared
theta okay
one's going to be brought up and the
other one's going to be minus one okay
so you can see that that one doesn't
give you real solutions okay so you can
ignore that but when you get to the a
corner okay
because so cos theta is plus or minus
uh-huh okay now this is two separate
ones right with two separate related
angles okay
FINA can be either if we're just talking
about single angles okay you can take
sixty degrees that will give you your
first quadrant solution right or what's
the second quarter solution it's 180
minus this right that's what all second
quadrant so it's 120
okay so if you want to go from specific
solutions these are two real any angles
base angles okay up to your general
solution what is general solution
because I'm in degrees by the way it's
the two times what they say it's 360
this is my 2pi plus or minus there's one
okay of course
ivar nor or and you can generate some
solutions we'll do it in a second
actually don't forget you introduced the
counter so don't just leave it hanging
out in middle so now what this okay now
to be fair I think that's fine I think
that's fine but you can go on better and
if the question underneath says no go
further than is the answer is actually
simpler which it is okay the question is
well how do I get from this to something
simpler okay so here's what I'm going to
suggest and this will often help you in
on any kind of situation where you are
two different general solutions and
you're trying to see if they coalesce
into some other sort of more unified way
okay so enjoy yourself out a number line
okay I'd recommend at least goes from
like zero to 720
you mean like Chia because when you're
going from here you see and all I'm
doing is I'm getting because actually
sorry this really said fine okay so if I
like the general solution what am I
going to stick in here okay all I want
is the the one most basic angle of it or
maybe this equation work okay if on the
other hand I was giving max specific
solutions from Norton 360 okay I would
say 60 and 120 and 240 and 300 okay
because it would hit all four quadrants
because it's plus or minus okay but
since what I'm really doing is leading
you on to general solution okay I only
want this one and this one if I were to
say you know 360 plus or minus 240 okay
this hand saw would actually overlap
with this answer but there would just be
an awkward way to say like why would you
use such a huge ending but I mean if you
want to use a few dangle why not go with
like 360 plus or minus like 600 because
that'd work - or 960 or whatever so just
by convention
well have a look at whatever value
you've got here and then you're related
angle will be either from it'll be
normally to 180 basically because if
it's positive
yeah if it's positive you'll be in the
first quadrant and if it's negative
positive will land in the first quadrant
of course it's negative like cuz there
is minus 1/2 they live in the second one
and you never need to go further because
I've already bought all the bases it was
signed because when you go from here to
here you don't get anything useful
okay instead of saying a bigger angle
you just say plus or minus right so
you're relating angle would be between
minus 90 and 90 so I can give you
another example in a second but I'll try
to finish the semester first all right
where it ought to be sorry I only tried
a number line okay and I'm going to put
these solutions on my number line and
see if I can notice any patterns
okay so first let's put some motors down
I'm almost there was really convenient
like okay so now when we have a look at
our solutions okay let's just do the
first one fescue 360 and plus or minus
60 okay so what my first solution is
gonna be I'll go to 0 plus or minus 60
right so did there's a solution there
would be a solution yet okay next load
over 360 plus or minus 60 it's a defect
and then my scaling it one more word
about 360 plus one six okay so there's
one set of solutions that corresponds to
this okay now I don't do the next one
120 okay yes I'm trying to sense patents
patents are easier when you've got a lot
as you'll see in a second if you're
verifying values though that's kind of
not gonna cut it right look at my pretty
lying with cross the seven it what does
that mean okay but as you see I do this
one you'll see the pattern
okay so plus or minus 120 plus or minus
and there's one next one over 360 plus
or minus okay and my last 100 plus all
over months okay now can you see kind of
a bit of the answers are much more
frequent than every 360 right which is
what the original general solutions
suggested he's like look every 360 you
should see a pair of answers okay it's
coming up more frequently than that
right because if I say take you spunky
on okay I can see solutions on each side
and the next Swan over
I can see solutions on each side
and same distance right and I don't have
to go in 360 degrees to find the next
one
I go from 180 to 360 540 okay so I'm
only copying 180 degrees every time and
then going plus or minus what's the
distance 60 right so therefore when you
put together these two okay what you're
really gonna get and this is what the
answers tell you with no explanation
they say well that's equal to 180 plus
or minus 60 okay now remember I told you
at the beginning right I think this is
funny
because this gives you all the solutions
and that's the only criteria that
general solution has okay and if the
question just said give me a general
solution you'd get full marks for that
okay however I mean if we quit on I
can't progress I think I wanna put on my
hair I don't think I've seen this if
they said sure that the general solution
was equal to this you know you wouldn't
be able to just write down this and then
go tada I'm awesome okay you'd have to
put down like this or you'd have to get
some values down so you can show you
demonstrate the patent that connects
this line to that one
yeah cuz this is hot like this took me a
while mid wanna see and think okay what
and I already knew what the answer was
okay so to demonstrate that here it's
smoke really worth it when that valid is
you mean like if I wanted to write this
yeah for sure you couldn't go from here
to here because once the the connection
is not clear at all right so I'm trying
to I'm trying to assess how much you
understand exactly right so if you went
about it another way
yeah Dennis would be a little more
obvious well you know when you go to in
PI
all right aggression is really I can't
think this is how rare happens I can't
think of an example off the top of my
head
and for what it's worth like every
everything really is like what we're
what we're looking for as a skill is
demonstrating and getting here so it's
kind of cool you see member laughing
it's just it's a handy thing it's more
than a different qualitative answer okay
everyone